foreign
[Music]
are the sum of our choices
and we cannot escape the past
Ethan this mission of yours
dearly
the world is changing
truth is Vanishing war is coming
it's been a long time
you've no idea the power I represent
it knows your story and How It Ends
[Music]
listen to me the world's coming after
you
his fate is written
shall we write yours too if anything
happens there's no place that I won't go
to kill you that is right now
Ethan what's your objective
what's your ultimate objective
your life will always matter more to me
than my own
none of our Lives can matter More Than
This Mission I don't accept that
[Music]
thank you foreign